like the people who say no always go
with your heart take the risk it's a
nice guiding principle but it shouldn't
be a hard and fast rule similarly no
stick with what you know do the safe
thing can be a good guiding principle
but you shouldn't stick to it hard and
fast so I think it somewhat depends on
your personality we all sort of fall
somewhere on the spectrum of risk
tolerance I think the best thing you can
do is like get to know yourself the
thing a lot of poker players have in
common is they would much rather Gamble
and lose than to have never had the
opportunity to gamble in the first place
so if you fall into that category you
know you take the risk a lot of the time
you lose but you can sort of stomach it
but that's fairly rare most people have
like a large loss aversion so there's
nothing wrong with that in fact it's
probably a healthier way of existing if
you're someone who's going to experience
more sort of suffering from having you
know taking a risky decision that then
doesn't work out that should come into
your Calculus and again if there's no
right or wrong answer it is very
subjective